hey david 10 of the trump rioters
were military doesn't this make trump's
coup
fantasy a real possibility so i think
there's a few important things to talk
about here
one is remember anytime we're talking
about a percentage we need to know what
the base rate is
the research i've done shows that seven
percent of the population
is veterans and uh just under
half a percent of the population is
currently active duty military
so military is was
over represented at the trump riots but
not dramatically so
overrepresented but not dramatically so
so active duty and
veterans are 7.4 percent of the
population and so far
1 in 10 defendants are uh military that
means that
10 instead of 7.4 percent that's about a
33 percent
over representation of military in the
trump
riot defenders okay good next question
uh could 10 of the military imagine that
10
of the military supported a coup for
donald trump
it's already the wrong math it's already
wrong math
10 of those willing to riot
are members of the military that does
not mean
10 of the military is willing to riot
to try to overthrow joe biden so the
numbers don't
the numbers don't even make sense but
more importantly
because of the military chain of command
even if 10 of the military was willing
able
and interested to participate in some
kind of insurrection to reinstall donald
trump and remove joe biden
it's just not enough it's just not
enough and it's been made
pretty clear and i know that there are
those who say they're just pretending
it's pretty clear that military
leadership
uh would not support anything
like what donald trump claims to be
dreaming up or what what it is claimed
donald trump is dreaming up
for august or whenever it's supposed to
be so
i think that there's a concern about yes
the over-representation of military
among the rioters
there's a concern about law enforcement
involvement
as a part of the january 6 riots
there are concerns that we could again
see violence in august when
again donald trump doesn't become
president of the united states
that's all for for sure no doubt about
it do i think that
even if 10 of the military um
wanted the coup they could make it
happen no i don't and remember
it's not 10 of the military are trump
coors
it's 10 of the rioters are current or
former
military so i don't think that this is
actually something
that we have to worry about i think we
have lots to worry about
i think there are concerns about will
things get violent i think there are
concerns about
to what degree will the republican party
continue to use the same
rhetoric that propped up
the january 6th rioters all of those are
concerns
what will the most committed q anon
trumpus do
when august comes and goes and again
donald trump is not president of the
united states
i don't have the answers to that but the
military is not
going to actually help donald trump
achieve this if you disagree with me
let me know you can find me on twitter
at deepakman we've got a great bonus
show for you today
you can get instant access to the bonus
show
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com
or by becoming a patron
at patreon.com david pakman show
one of the best ways that you can
support what we do at the david pakman
show is supporting some of our awesome
sponsors today one of those awesome
sponsors is sheath
underwear a lot of us know all too well
about the sticking and the rubbing and
the chafing with traditional
underwear especially this time of year
as the weather is getting
warm sheath underwear have created
unique boxer briefs with multiple
ergonomic compartments in the front
preventing skin on skin contact
everything stays
separate comfortable dry and cool
no more sweatiness no more chafing no
more readjusting it's a lifesaver
sheath underwear is giving the david
pakman show audience
20 off when you go to sheath underwear
dot com slash pacman
and use the promo code pacman give
sheath underwear a shot
i've had a great experience i believe
you will too you can find the link
underneath this video and don't forget
to use
promo code pacman for 20 off